hello everybody a very good morning to
you it is seven o'clock wherever you're
watching us around the world you are
very welcome to the sky news breakfast
show punishing partygate the first finds
could be issued in the coming hours for
those dining street allegations could
the prime minister be among them big
question mark plus claims about a
russian oligarch and a poisoning in
ukraine we're joined on today's show by
labour's deputy leader angela rainer for
her views on all of that plus we'll talk
to the children's minister will quince
also joined by the phones for you
founder who wants to open up his home to
refugees and what next in the scandal
engulfing piano ferries as its boss
prepares to face questions we'll talk to
one of the 800 workers sacked by the
company it's tuesday the 29th of march
investigating party gates sky news
understands more than 20 fines could be
issued today
u.s intelligence doubt overclaims the
russian oligarch roman abramovich and
ukrainian peace negotiators were
poisoned on ukrainian territory
i'm live in lev as ukrainian and russian
officials meet in turkey for peace talks
with early signs that ukraine may be
willing to compromise but hopes for a
breakthrough remain low
inside maria paul new pictures show the
devastation in the city as ukrainian
forces say they've retaken open and some
other towns
[Music]
will smith says he was out of line for
slapping chris rock amid calls to strip
him of his oscar
i'm live in dover as yet another piano
ferry has been detained as the company
boss faces yet more questions on the
math sackings
also coming up on the programme for you
this morning remembering prince philip
the queen and prince andrew expected to
attend a special thanksgiving we'll talk
to one of the late duke's friends plus
the royal photographer arthur edwards
will be with us on the programme
and we speak to a filmmaker who traveled
to ukraine to help rescue a former
circus bear from war in the country
[Music]
good morning everybody busy day ahead
today first to tell you that in the
coming hours we could get the first find
for partygate could the pm himself be
receiving one of those fines sky news
understands that up to 20 fines could be
issued over events held in downing
street and whitehall during the
coronavirus lockdowns
met police have revealed that more than
a hundred questionnaires have been
issued the police force launched an
investigation at the end of january into
12 alleged events that happened on eight
dates during england's lockdowns in 2020
and 2021 to see if covid regulations
were broken the pm is known to have
attended at least two gatherings under
investigation the prime minister and
rishi sunak have both received
questionnaires we'll be watching
developments on the story very closely
for you our other main story today and
face-to-face peace talks between russia
and ukraine are due to resume this
morning in turkey now it's amid a
backdrop of a remarkable claim about the
poisoning of a russian oligarch roman
abramovich
let's take a look at some of the key
developments you're waking up to on that
story this morning
the ukrainian military claims to have
retaken the city of urpin north west to
of kiev alongside the settlements of
kamyanka and tapolski in the kharkiv
region
the united states also believes the
ukrainians have now regained control of
the towns of trotsdenets south of sumi
in the east
general staff of the armed forces of
ukraine say russian forces are weakened
and disorientated cut off from logistics
the british ministry of defence says
russia will deploy more than a thousand
mercenaries from the wagner group to
eastern ukraine
while amnesty international has accused
russia of committing war crimes in the
port city of mariopol
on ahead of the peace talks in istanbul
this morning ukraine's foreign minister
had this warning in light of the
reported poisoning of roman abramovich
i advise anyone going for negotiations
with the russian federation not to eat
or drink anything and preferably avoid
touching any surface that's it first
hand
secondly all these stories
someone heard something somewhere some
sources
now there is a lot of this kind because
everyone is thirsty for news for
sensation
sally's joining us from live now the
talks uh continuing further this morning
but this specter of poisoning in the air
as well we're told sally tell us more
good morning
morning 2k yeah absolutely extraordinary
stuff isn't it i should uh make clear
that those talks that roman abramovich
attended in kiev earlier this month
where there was this uh suspected uh
poisoning of him and two ukrainian
officials they are separate to the
formal talks that are beginning in
turkey today there's lots of other talks
going on behind the scenes uh which
roman of abramovic appears to be
involved with but it certainly goes to
show the very low starting point for
these peace talks between ukrainian and
russian officials which begin today in
istanbul if the foreign minister for
ukraine is advising negotiators not to
eat or drink anything but certainly
there does appear to be the signs of
early signs i should say of potential
concessions uh being made on both sides
uh president zielenski yesterday saying
that uh he was prepared to declare
neutrality for ukraine and offer a
referendum on nato membership which of
course has been one of
president putin's big demands that
ukraine wouldn't seek
nato membership and the financial times
is reporting today that they've spoken
to four sources close to the talks and
close to these negotiations
who claim that uh vladimir putin is also
willing to potentially accept eu
membership for ukraine provided they
aren't aligned militarily with any
alliance such as nato so could that be
the early bones of a plan well who knows
certainly as i say trust is low we know
that what russia says and what it does
can be two very different things and
certainly there is a concern here in
ukraine that president putin could be
using these negotiations these peace
talks in turkey as a smoke screen
to revitalize and reorganize his
exhausted troops
okay for now thanks so much indeed
thanks a lot well we've seen some new
pictures from mario paul of the
destruction caused by russia's
invasion of ukraine residents of the
coastal city were seen yesterday
collecting their belongings from heavily
damaged apartment buildings and
gathering food supplies among the debris
the mayor of mario paul has called for
all civilians to be evacuated from the
encircled ukrainian city to allow them
to escape a humanitarian catastrophe the
mayor says 160 000 civilians were still
trapped in the city on the sea of azov
without heat and power after weeks of
russian bombardment
nothing is left i tell you i live in a
bath house i have a small bathhouse and
a stove and that's it there is no roof
there is nothing
37 years i proudly worked as a shoemaker
and was left with nothing
no workshop
no work nothing
somehow i should hold on
i have to
we had a beautiful life just beautiful
great pensions children had wonderful
work both of my sons-in-law have been
working now we have nothing we're left
homeless just homeless they have broken
everything we have nowhere to go
i'm going to have more from ukraine
throughout the course of the programme
for you here on sky news this morning
including a circus bear that has been
rescued and is now safely out of the
country and in romania what happens to
it next stay tuned and finite meantime
will smith has apologized to chris rock
for slapping him at the oscars ceremony
the actor told his instagram followers
that his behavior was out of line a
mother won't be a criminal investigation
the academy have opened a formal review
someone who's been in the heart of
hollywood for the drama is our u.s
correspondent greg milam who sent us
this report
it isn't quite time to declare the
oscars dead but this sums up the somber
mood in the heart of hollywood
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see it all right
[Applause]
oh richard
oh wow
wow
one ugly moment on its biggest night has
left the movie industry reeling
will smith posting this apology violence
in all its forms is poisonous and
destructive he wrote his behavior
unacceptable and inexcusable for
reacting emotionally to jokes about his
wife he said he apologized to chris rock
his actions not indicative of the man he
wants to be
the question is whether that's enough
for an oscars academy which has
condemned his actions and launched a
formal review
some even suggesting taking away that
oscar he danced with at the after party
in the industry they think he's done
huge damage to his career i don't think
that there's any chance that they would
rescind his oscar which is for a
performance i've seen that uh written on
social media that's not what's going to
happen but they could do um a lot of
things
up to including expel them from the
academy this is going to
mark his career forever
as they pack up for another year this
feels like just the latest crisis for
the oscars
for a few years now the academy has
faced questions about the relevance of
the oscars today and some pretty big
controversies as well but nothing on
this scale now they face questions about
how you handle one of hollywood's
biggest stars when he oversteps the mark
on its biggest stage
will smith's hands already have a place
in hollywood legend changed the world he
wrote that day how much will those hands
now have changed the course of his
career greg milam sky news los angeles
well joining us now is the children's
and families minister will quince bit
poorly this morning mr quince you've got
kovid which is why you can't be with us
in the studio we wish you better thank
you for taking the time to join us this
morning should we start with um uh will
smith given that we were talking about
it there um the academy has said or one
academy member has said it's a shameful
act of stupidity and violence what did
you make of it when you saw it yesterday
morning
oh well okay my view i'm sorry i can't
be in the studio i would love to have
joined you the the it's so disappointing
because i'm a huge fan of will smith and
i think violence is never ever the
answer and you know i say this as an
education minister because as part of
our rhse curriculum we we know people
can lose their tempers we know people
can say hurtful things but violence is
never ever the answer and it's just so
unfortunate to see such a high profile
figure reacting that way having said
that i do welcome the fact that he
apologized almost immediately yesterday
and he apologized again to chris rock
that was the right thing to do but i
hope he reflects on his behavior because
he is a big role model and you know
violence is never ever the answer should
he keep his oscar
that's a matter for the the academy he
hasn't he has apologized um but but as i
say i i hope the message goes out loud
and clear that you know people can say
some very hurtful things i have no doubt
kate people said hurtful things about
you i i know people have about me
twitter in particular um but the answer
is never ever violence so matter for the
academy but i hope a message goes out
that he was wrong to do it he's rightly
apologized
yeah never read the comments on twitter
that's my top tip minister there'd be
dragons there um as far as roman
abramovich's concern suggestions that he
was poisoned during peace talks um what
form should an investigation take do you
think
well that's a matter for the local
authority it didn't take place in the uk
although no doubt uk government will be
looking to establish the facts there um
it is a a
worrying development though i know
you'll agree
and as far as advice is concerned for
those taking part in those peace talks
we've heard from the ukrainian foreign
minister saying don't drink or eat
anything or touch anything i'm guessing
that would be something that the british
government would echo
well it's not a place but for me as an
education minister to to say that but
but no doubt those are wise in these
issues we'll be able to give uh such
advice but you know i
i was just watching your clip there okay
the situation in ukraine is just
horrific it's heartbreaking to watch and
my thoughts are with the 7.5 plus
million children in ukraine who often
the unseen victims in conflicts of this
nature and you know as as much as there
is skepticism globally about whether
these peace talks will be successful i
desperately hope that they they are and
on
any terms that are acceptable to
ukrainian president and ukrainian people
to that end um we are seeing adverts in
the papers this morning um offering a
home to uh ukrainian refugees but i'm
still a bit confused about this homes
for ukrainians scheme as to how many
people have actually applied or are
being allowed into the uk are we not
slightly putting the cart before the
horse by putting ads in the papers when
we've not sorted out the details yet
no so i think the details are in place
so so there's two schemes live at the
moment and the the first thing which is
the family scheme we've had about twenty
three thousand people uh exceptional
scheme of about eight thousand of those
children understandably with an
education brief i'm keeping a very
watchful eye on that and i know that
number will will increase and then and
then on the other scheme which is
relation to the host ukraine the british
people have been absolutely incredible
over 150 000 of uh expressed in interest
you know the numbers of that are
relatively low at the moment in terms of
coming over here but many many are in in
progress and you know i want to thank
from the bottom of my heart everyone
who's reached out seeing those terrible
scenes in ukraine and is offering up
their home
yeah but the refugees minister saying
just yesterday i think that he can't
tell us at this stage um how many um
ukrainians have been admitted into the
uk when will we know how many have
actually come
yeah so under the first scheme is 23 000
8 000 of which children my understanding
is on the homes for ukraine scheme it's
it's over a thousand but you'll see a a
massive escalation of that look i know
that officials that both home office
deluxe and fcdo the foreign office are
working at pace seven days a week to to
get as many people into safety in here
to the united kingdom as possible
talk to me about your send green paper
explain to my viewers this morning what
that means and what the hopes are
yeah thanks again hugely exciting we're
launching our ambitious new plans to
transform the outcomes for children and
young people with special educational
needs
and those who are in alternative
provision and it's very hard
excuse me sorry it's about a a strong
national system percent making it really
inclusive giving more clarity for
parents at the moment ending that
postcode lottery that exists and really
importantly strengthening accountability
and redress within the system but it's
very hard it's about making sure that
every child regardless of the challenge
they face is get a yes a world-class
education here in our country and it's
the start of a 13-week consultation and
i encourage as many parents children and
young people with special education
needs and all those who work within the
system to take part
27 of children living in
poverty rishi sunax implied he'll offer
no more help on energy bills until at
least the autumn
what happens to people who can't pay
their energy bills between now and then
so kenny he's already put 22 billion
pounds of support in place this year 9.1
billion
with regards to energy and there's also
the household supports fund which has
been doubled from 500 million to a
billion pounds local authorities are
often best placed to identify those who
need that additional support but i was
the um minister of work and pensions
throughout the pandemic and throughout
the pandemic both the chancellor and the
prime minister at no point failed to
step up and support the poorest and most
disadvantaged in our country and
although there's lots of uncertainty
around the energy market over the coming
months and commodity prices and other
things i know the chancellor has kept me
a really watchful eye and all i would
say is you know judge both the prime
minister and the chancellor by their
record they have never failed to step up
previously and i know if the needs arise
they'll step up again okay um brace
yourself uh mr quince here comes the
party gate question should the prime
minister resign if he is fined
so okay i entirely understand why you
asked that question i understand the
huge public interest i i completely
understand the considerable
upset caused the events that took place
shouldn't shouldn't have happened but i
hope you'll understand that both as an
education minister but more importantly
as
there's an ongoing live metropolitan
police investigation it's just not
appropriate that i comment no but we are
expecting fines today if one of them is
for the prime minister should he resign
no that's a hypothetical question okay i
you wouldn't expect me to answer that i
know you'd like me to be an education
minister we both know what hypothetical
means and of course it is not a
hypothetical question so hopefully this
pointless me pressing you on it because
you won't answer it so let me ask you
this instead how soon can we expect the
full su grey report after the fines have
been issued
so i think my understanding is the prime
minister has been been clear that as
soon as the metropolitan police have
concluded their investigation then um
sue grace report was handed to the
government will be will be published i
think the prime minister also said he'll
make a full statement to the house as
well and i think you know one thing to
say okay you know looking at the moment
over in uh ukraine and even even worse
over in in russia you know i i think
it's a brilliant thing that we have a
free press in this country that's able
to ask these kind of questions these are
the questions that couldn't be asked in
putin's regime in in russia i think it's
a it's a great thing yeah but it doesn't
mean that you answer the question just
because i ask it does it
well no i i think we need to wait for
the police the metro and police
investigation to conclude i completely
understand why you answered the question
i hope you understand why it wouldn't be
appropriate for me to answer it okay i
do wish you better is this the first
time you've had covid it it is it is
okay you and i have got a shared passion
i i love love seeing the pictures of
your dogs i i grew up with irish setters
and i love them
yeah okay you've won me over i will
i wish you better look after yourself
we'll speak to you soon i look forward
to seeing you in the studio thank you
thank you nice to see you
he won that one didn't he uh let's have
a quick look at what's happening as far
as the papers are concerned this morning
daily telegraph says that scotland yard
is expected to issue the first fines
over partygate after concluding coveted
laws were broken at the heart of the
government the guardian also reports on
the story adding that multiple
government insiders have said the
metropolitan police will issue the fixed
penalty notices
imminently and that is not hypothetical
that's also on the front of the daily
mirror party gate first finds is their
headline
and that one says something different as
well about abramovic still to come on
the program for you later in the show
we'll get labour's take speaking to the
deputy leader angela raynor as delegates
from ukraine and russia arrive for
further peace talks we'll speak to a
former nato representative lord peter
ricketts
and also bring you the latest on the
planned shanghai lockdown with benjamin
cowling chair professor of epidemiology
at the university of hong kong
before that a piano ferry has been
detained by the maritime and coast guard
agency after failing a safety test the
pride of kent is being held at the port
of dover the second of the firm's
vessels to be detained in just three
days we sent ashna down to dover to find
out it's a bit clearer there this
morning than it was yesterday ashna two
of their ferries now detained
yeah that's right okay as you mentioned
three days ago one in northern ireland
in llam the european causeway vessel was
uh detained they failed on the grounds
of crew familiarization crew training
and vessel documentation and yet again
this is the scandal isn't it that's just
escalating day by day the government
piling yet more pressure on the company
to give those 800 seafarers their jobs
back if they want them calling for the
ceo to resign and now their second boat
to fail this inspection it's an
inspection carried out by the maritime
and coast guard agency they're
essentially carrying out these safety
checks preliminary checks to check that
the vessels are safe to operate this is
the dover to calais route and the pride
of kent it is one of their most
frequently used uh vessels and they
failed not clear yet on what grounds
they did fail though this is a company
that's reputation says the trump
transport secretary grant shaps his
reputation is in tatters he said that
the company had little choice but to
give those seafarers their jobs back and
you can see now protest pictures we have
seen so many protests up and down the
country from liverpool to hull to dover
people not letting this one go the ceo
peter hebelthwaite is due to sit in
front of a committee at the scottish
parliament later this morning plenty
more questions for him on those math
sackings but just the latest development
in this growing saga
okay thank you
let's take a look at some of today's
other headlines for you now the queen
and prince andrew are expected to attend
a memorial service today marking the
life of a late husband the duke of
edinburgh the service of thanksgiving is
being held at westminster abbey the
original venue for prince philip's
funeral until it was moved to windsor
due to covert restrictions
my old mate jeff stelling has decided to
stay on as host of soccer saturday on
sky sports for at least another season
uh it says he's 67 he can't be announced
last october that he would be leaving
the role at the end of 2021-22 campaign
but he's changed his mind saying he was
not ready to blow the final whistle and
leave the best job in the world he's
wrong because i've got the best job in
the world now millions of lives could be
saved from drug resistant infections by
a new breakthrough antibiotic
developed by uk scientists there's also
hope the superbug mrsa which is commonly
spread through hospitals could be
eradicated after the team successfully
got rid of it in a study on mice
teachers in florida have been banned
from giving lessons on sexual
orientation and gender identity to
children under the age of nine ron
desantis the state governor signed the
contentious don't say gay bill into law
on monday
so those little people even know what
was going on there ukraine and russia
are set to hold their first face-to-face
peace talks in more than two weeks in
istanbul joining us is lord ricketts
former permanent undersecretary at the
foreign office and former british
permanent representative to nato hello
to you thanks for joining us on the
programme this morning let's talk about
that poisoning first of all alleged
poisoning the americans are pouring a
bit of cold water on it but there is um
you know previous obviously from russia
on poisoning people how concerned should
those taking part in the peace talks be
i think they all want to be very careful
indeed i mean we don't know what
happened it's quite mysterious
the problem is it could well have
happened because as you say the russians
have a long track record a kind of
morbid fascination with poisons and
chemical weapons so it is entirely
possible that somebody made an effort to
disrupt this informal mediation which is
i think what abramovich others were
trying to do so yeah i'm sure the
ukrainian negotiators in turkey and
indeed the turkish hosts will be being
extremely careful
yeah what's your advice to them people
taking part in peace talks with the
russians
well i i think uh depend on your turkish
hosts i think today this is an
initiative by president erdogan i'm sure
he will do everything possible to keep
everybody safe at the venue but it is
you know a very very depressing
conclusion that you can't trust uh
russian negotiators and sit down with
them without worrying that there might
be some awful poisoning to be done
what um sort of steps would you take my
lord if you were taking part in peace
negotiations with face to face with the
russian entourage
i think i'd stick with the turkish
supplied
nibbles and water and stay off anything
else
a very good advice
talk to me about president zielinski he
was talking i think on sunday night and
uh he says he's now willing to discuss
neutral status in exchange for peace how
should we interpret that
i think everybody wants this terrible
war to be over and we'd all love to
think that negotiations could produce a
breakthrough soon in the ceasefire and
i've absolutely no doubt that president
zielenski and the ukrainian side are
totally sincere but i'm really wary of
the russians here i don't honestly see
that the conditions are there for a
meaningful ceasefire
i think it's brave of president
zielinski to face up to the fact that
ukraine is not going to join nato
anytime soon he's interested in security
guarantees from the major powers and a
neutral status of ukraine possibly with
the right to join the eu
all these are important but they're
frankly secondary issues the key thing
is what happens to this territory that
russian forces have occupied i do not
believe that putin will be willing to
give up uh places like mario paul once
they do hold it firmly that's on the
corridor between the east which russia
already controls and the south and the
crimean peninsula i'm afraid his minimum
objective is to hold the territory that
he's now occupied
that requires ukraine to accept
effectively the partition of their
country and i just find it very hard to
imagine that any ukrainian government
could do that so i'm pretty skeptical
about the outcome of these talks
although it's a good thing people are
talking yeah even though the alternative
is the pictures that we've just been
looking at where parts of ukraine are
literally being bombed into oblivion
peace talks mean that both sides have to
give
yes they do
but they mean that ukraine would have to
be prepared to give up large slices of
the country
which would be a kind of reward for
russian conquest and occupation
i think it's perhaps more likely that at
some point the fighting will diminish
that there'll be some sort of truce and
a uneasy partition across the line of
separation neither side accepting that
is the outcome
that might be a help for ukrainian
citizens and enable humanitarian help
and so on to them but it will be
unstable and it will guarantee that
fighting will flare up again in the
future i don't want to predict that but
i think that's probably more likely than
a signed and sealed peace deal any time
in the foreseeable future
diplomacy all important in peace talks
especially when you're dealing with a
country like russia how helpful was
president biden's comments at the
weekend weekend when it seemed that he
was suggesting that regime change in
russia was the only option
well i think he'd done extremely well on
this visit to europe he'd had a series
of summits in brussels i think which
he'd played brilliantly i think the
alliance feels stronger as a result
personally i think that remark about
effectively meaning regime change in
moscow was a mistake
because i think we need to keep the
focus on ending this war
and leave the future of president putin
to the russians i think putting russian
uh president putin in a corner feeling
that that the objective of the west is
to oust him will only make things more
difficult and i know that his comments
have been um kind of corrected uh the
sense of perhaps went going a bit
further than he intended in those
remarks i think the real thing is to get
this war over uh and i think declaring
our objective is to ask president putin
is a mistake
okay my lord it's always good to talk to
you thank you for sparing the time we do
appreciate it
thank you
thank you um the latest pictures let's
have a look at these these are from the
peace talks in turkey istanbul to be
precise
we're expecting the russians and
ukrainians to gather again today first
time in a couple of weeks that we've
seen uh peace talks going ahead and
you've also seen you're waking up to
news this morning that roman abramovich
suggesting along with two others that he
had been poisoned during previous peace
talks in ukraine he said he'd had water
and a bar of chocolate but just a short
while afterwards his skin started to
peel from his face he says and
his was temporarily blinded until the
morning
those attending their peace talks in
istanbul have been told to be very
cautious about what they eat and drink
during the process
sally is in la vie forest and she'll
bring us the very latest on what's
happening in ukraine coming up shortly
meantime the met office is increasing
the temperature threshold for when a
heat wave is declared across eight
english counties now the weather would
have have to hit
28. uh 28 degrees i should say which is
82 in old money for three days in a row
in surrey cambridge berkshire
buckinghamshire bedfordshire and
hertfordshire where hurricanes hardly
ever happen the cap in the east riding
of yorkshire has increased to 26 degrees
from 25 i think that means global
warming is uh taking its toll on our
temperatures what's it going to do today
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
a northerly wind will make it much
colder over the next few days and will
bring wintry showers to some it's mostly
mild rather dull and foggy now with
outbreaks of rain over southern england
and the far north
peace talks will resume today between
ukraine and russia after claims
ukrainian negotiators were poisoned
alongside russian oligarch roman
abramovich during a meeting in kiev
will smith has apologized to chris rock
for slapping him at the oscars ceremony
saying his behavior was unacceptable and
inexcusable
and investigating partygate in downing
street sky news understands more than 20
fines could be issued today
let's get more now on that story what
might happen if the pm is fined in the
partygate investigation earlier i spoke
to the children's and family minister
wilkins he wasn't quite open to
answering the question
yeah i entirely understand why you asked
that question i understand the huge
public interest
i completely understand the considerable
upset caused the events that took place
shouldn't shouldn't have happened but i
hope you'll understand that both as an
education minister but more importantly
as
there's an ongoing live metropolitan
police investigation it's just not
appropriate that i comment no but we are
expecting fines today if one of them is
for the prime minister should he resign
no that's a hypothetical question okay
you wouldn't expect me to answer that i
know you'd like me to an education
minister we both know what hypothetical
means and of course it is not a
hypothetical question
no there we go um tamara is here with us
this morning so
today we could see some fines yes could
quickly become a very real question for
the prime minister because don't forget
before the ukraine conflict broke out
just over a month ago westminster was
ablaze with talk about partygate all
these parties that allegedly occurred in
downing street during the lockdown in
breach of the rules some of them
attended by the prime minister and we
know that he was one of the first to get
one of these metropolitan police
questionnaires asking him about yeah
chancellor got one as well we believe
the prime minister's wife and the
cabinet secretary the most senior civil
servant got one too so if he was one of
the first does that mean he may be
issued with a penalty charge notice
today a fine we simply don't know we
know this is the first batch that the
met will be issuing but we don't know
exactly whether it's going to be say the
open and shut cases we have had
civil servants sort of admitting on
social media that they broke the rules
will they be the ones given the fines
first or will it be the people who
answered the questions first no one in
government even in number 10 really
knows exactly how it's going to work
they only know that they are poised for
the metropolitan police to issue the
first batch today around 20 fines not
necessarily 20 people there may be some
people who've got more than one but the
investigation is now up and running
again it will continue running at the
end of it sue grey's full report with
all the details will be released but
this brings back questions over the
prime minister's leadership and judgment
you heard the minister there saying um
he understands how upset people were
about it the big question of course is
are people still are people still very
upset our mps who called for the prime
minister to resign only a couple of
months ago still as upset as they were
and what are they going to do about it
what's your take on that what do you
think well look if the prime minister
gets a penalty charge notice if he's
found to have committed a crime that is
of course incredibly serious and
whatever has happened since doesn't take
away from the seriousness of that of
course the timing here matters hugely
though because um if we are still
embroiled in this conflict and mps for
it's the wrong time to make a challenge
if they feel the circumstances have
changed and this is less serious than it
appeared or there simply wasn't the
numbers um before because of course you
needed half the party to have um voted
against the prime minister in no
confidence vote
to bring him down so may we will we
don't know whether even at the height of
this there were the numbers there to do
that so it's going to be a real test of
the strength of feeling on this issue
okay tomorrow's take nine o'clock see
you then looking forward to it thank you
meantime shanghai has been divided in
half for a two-part lockdown which will
see authorities roll out an experimental
covert testing regime chinese city
has been battling a new coronavirus
surge for nearly a month benjamin
cowling chair professor of epidemiology
at the university of hong kong is with
us now good morning to you thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
how should we
read what is happening in shanghai how
concerned should we be
china china is still doing the zero
covert approach so they still want to
keep the virus out of the community and
if there are outbreaks they want to stop
it as quick as possible it looks like
there was a bit of hesitancy in shanghai
about doing a total lockdown doing the
mass universal testing but is now
finally going ahead if it had been done
a week or two ago the case numbers would
have been lower now it's about 5 000 a
day
okay although it looking at the numbers
of um
infections as opposed to deaths it's not
that bad is it it's not that high to
lock down a whole city second city of
millions and millions of people
well that's true but what we what we
know is with covid it just the numbers
keep getting larger and larger and
larger so if you do a lock down at 50 a
day you stop it from going to 100 to 500
a day to a thousand to 5 000 a day if
they didn't do it now then in a week's
time they'd have 10 000 even 50 000 a
day so they got to do it sooner
otherwise the numbers will keep getting
bigger and bigger and then that's when
you start seeing the impact on the
healthcare system that's infections
though isn't it not deaths 50
symptomatic cases
3450 asymptomatic infections the british
government has made the decision that
kovid is an infection a disease that we
have to a virus that we have to live
with
now the chinese looking at it very
differently
well the level of immunity in china is
lower because they have not had many
infections in the past two years unlike
the uk and at the same time the vaccine
coverage while it's very high overall in
china it's more than 80
in elderly it's not that high and if you
could look at hong kong you can see what
can happen if there's a lot of
infections in a population with
relatively lower vaccine coverage in the
elderly
in hong kong we had 7 000 deaths in the
matter of uh two months that's 0.1
percent of the population dying within
just two months and in china the
healthcare system is fragile uh if
there's a lot of serious cases which
could happen if this uh the current
outbreak is not stopped it could get a
lot worse
we had the
education secretary former vaccines
minister nadim zahawi on the programme
yesterday he told us that a zero covered
strategy simply doesn't work certainly
here in the uk what would you say in
response
i think it would have been difficult in
the uk two years ago to get cases
completely down to zero and then keep
them at zero but other parts of the
world have managed it i think singapore
and new zealand are great examples of
how xerocovid can save lives in the
short term but then you have to plan to
move away from it and in china the
difference is there's no current plan to
exit zero covert the strategy is zero
covered until further notice and that
that will pose problems because the
impact of the zero covert policies will
just keep getting bigger and bigger
okay great to talk to you thanks so much
indeed for your expertise much
appreciated
just uh hearing from the turkish leader
erdogan he's saying negotiations that's
uh in istanbul of course where the
negotiations for ukraine are uh trying
to bring peace to ukraine are going
ahead as we speak
he says the negotiation process has
increased hopes uh quick listen guidance
of your leaders
we are ready to make any contributions
that will make your jobs easier
today i'm going to tashkent
to
[Music]
to give you
it is possible to reach a solution that
will address the legitimate concerns of
both countries and that the
international community will accept us
trustworthy
i believe
you will not refrain from taking
initiatives to restore peace
as you know
he also said that a fair piece will not
have a loser conflict continuing
benefits no one uh words uh from the
turkish leader ahead of those continuing
peace talks you'll know that talks that
had taken place in ukraine that also
involved roman abramovich the russian
oligarchy used to own chelsea football
club of course i think he still owns
simply can't do anything with it
had allegedly
had three people poisoned during those
talks including abramovich himself he
said that he lost his sight and he also
had skin peeling from his face after
drinking a bottle of water and eating
chocolate at the talks as a result the
ukrainian foreign leader has told those
taking part in the talks today in
istanbul to touch nothing
uh now let's uh let's see if we can get
simon colder should we on the program um
he is standing by for us i think in
lithuania this morning
hi simon
okay yes yes good morning from the hill
of crosses in northern lithuania just
outside the city of xiaoli and this is a
place of pilgrimage for the lithuanians
and indeed a lot of polish people a
symbol of resistance would you believe
against them soviet and in particular
russian domination being called those
several times by the red army but it's
still here tens of thousands of crosses
and uh i'm just here enjoying the uh
bright spring sunshine uh traveling
around the borderlands of course
lithuania boarded by uh by latvia by
poland but also by belarus and by russia
estonia as well
particularly latvia estonia lithuania
where you are
bargain holidays at the moment is that
because of what's happening in ukraine
uh it seems to be as an awful lot of
people who are being put off traveling
not just in the three baltic republics
but also to uh to poland to romania to
hungary to slovakia all of them
fantastic destinations all of them
horrific conflict the russian war being
waged on ukraine um absolutely safe and
indeed the one problem you might find
certainly here is that uh there's quite
a lot of western soldiers stationed here
and they're actually taking up much of
the hotel space but my goodness the
bargains here it cost me eight pounds to
fly out here from luton um i've paid
nearly twice as much coming back from
tallinn but there's definitely bargains
to be had
meanwhile back in the uk goodness me
gatwick airport ramping up um uh
starting this morning uh just an hour
and twenty minutes ago the very
first va euro flyer thing took off gay
uh going from um gatwick to monaco in
cyprus currently over southern germany
um and that marked the complete shift uh
basically number of flight uh from from
gatwick has pretty much doubled since uh
since sunday and
long queues developing at manchester i'm
afraid the airport there says they've
got lots of staff shortage huge problems
with security
uh people um well one person this
morning who got there about three in the
morning he said she got through security
in five minutes others are complaining
of waiting hours the airport says they
are training more security staff but
they're just asking people to get there
good and early we have problems over in
dublin similar issues
you can't literally get the stuff and
you certainly can't suddenly recruit
them and put them on security they've
all got to be checked of course
okay um great backdrop there simon thank
you so much for taking the time to tell
us what's happening in lithuania today
thank you
um
i just want to
tell you what's happening with these
peace talks um they are the latest peace
talks for ukraine and we just want to
dip in and out as we're hearing both
from the um leader of turkey but also
the ukrainian deputy prime minister is
speaking about it as well and he's
saying within the last few moments that
he hopes to open three humanitarian
corridors today
including for private vehicles from
mario paul we've seen those pictures
haven't we from mario paul and basically
it's been absolutely pounded by the
russians the latest death and injury
figures um are just astronomical i think
i read that 5 000 civilians have been
killed in mario paul we're just hearing
from the ukrainian deputy prime minister
saying that ukraine aims to open three
humanitarian corridors uh including for
private cars from mario paul and that
from later on today let's hope that goes
ahead we've seen previously when those
corridors are open that uh those
civilians have been targeted as they
tried to flee hopefully that will not be
the case today we'll wait to see
meantime sri lanka is going through its
worst economic crisis in decades the
country is running out of money to pay
for imports of food and fuel and has
asked india to help with a billion
dollar bailout well let's take you to
delhi should we never standing by for us
with the very latest what's caused this
problem neville good morning
morning cave well there there there were
internal problems and also external
issues of corvid because uh tourism is a
big uh earner for for sri lanka and
because of kovit for the last two years
uh it has actually crowd the tourism
industry has crashed then you have the
war in ukraine which has affected the
rise in in fuel prices uh
and and coupled with that is uh the
reckless and uh bad policies by the
present government
which has
made
sort of
the the situation even worse the they
cannot control the spiraling inflation
in the country
in the last month itself food essentials
has has risen by almost 25 percent uh
the sri lankan rupee has dropped in this
month itself by 45 percent against the
dolo and it's uh it's depleting the
foreign exchange reserves of the country
and they are
they cannot afford to buy another food
uh and import food essentials and also
fuel so much so that the power ministry
has ordered a shutdown of of electricity
for almost seven eight hours a day
in this in this period of time and uh
for the time being it doesn't seem to
go any better for the ordinary sri
lankans
uh in in uh in the country and we've
seen protests by them uh every day now
thanks thank you
uh meantime the mayor of islam is the uh
in the east of uh ukraine has led
residents in evacuating the city after
relentless russian shelling in the
kharkiv region isiam was said to be at
breaking point as early as two weeks ago
when diminishing food and water supplies
were reported let's take a look at the
current state of the conflict
intense fighting continues around
mariopol where russia has gained the
most ground according to uk defense
intelligence meanwhile the second city
of kharkiv has been shelled
over 200 times this week alone according
to its governor and ukrainian military
officials claiming russia is moving
additional forces towards the border
in the nearby town of isiam the mayor
has fled along with many residents
pursued by russian destruction
and shelling our correspondent john
sparks has this report from the
outskirts of the time
vladimir putin had a vision of a
decisive victory in ukraine
but his operation has stalled and his
generals have drawn up new
plans they say they'll liberate the
territory of eastern ukraine like the
city of israel and the communities which
surround it
but after four weeks of warfare the
residents now fear annihilation
schools and shops have been leveled and
family homes bombed from the air
[Laughter]
mikola and lubov have lived in this
house for 32 years
what's the point of this what do you
think the point of this is
[Music]
not
foreign
russia has had its eyes on the east for
years backing separatists in the region
since 2014
but its territorial ambitions are not
supported here i asked a local official
whether he was ready to be liberated
this school has been
absolutely
obliterated but it's not the only thing
that's been damaged in this village that
clinic has been shelled and
there are dozens of ordinary homes that
have been destroyed as well and it is
difficult to see
any military rationale for this
that's a question the people of israel
will ask
their city subject to weeks of intense
fighting with inner city areas now
largely destroyed we understand
an estimated 20 000 are trapped in this
community cut off from the rest of
ukraine
thousands of people from isiam were able
to escape and they've been accommodated
in district schools in kindergartens
this one accommodates 19
and everybody wanted answers from the
mayor
will i have a place to return to said a
woman called galena
the mayor said everything would be all
right
galena has been told that russian
soldiers are now living in her ism
apartment
there
the hours and days stretch in front of
them separated from the people and the
things that they love
there is little comfort here and no
prospect of peace
john sparks sky news in eastern ukraine
or on ukraine in just a moment but want
to bring you the very latest on our top
story this morning party gate just when
the prime minister thought it was safe
to leave down the street again it would
appear that 20 people no 20 fines not 20
people 20 fines are likely to be issued
as early as today on partygate we don't
know who it will be that we'll be
receiving those fines at this stage but
we do know that the prime minister and
also the chancellor were had to fill in
a questionnaire please question her
under caution so we'll have the latest
on that we'll also take you to mario
paul where we're being told that
humanitarian corridors are going to be
opened again that's off the back of news
goodness me look what's happened there
off the back of peace talks continuing
in istanbul